Hey everybody, welcome to the podcast.
Today's episode is the maiden voyage
of a brand new format of our show exclusively for you too
that we're calling rollback.
Which is essentially an opportunity
for us to share the best episodes
from our audio only catalog with you guys.
I've been doing this podcast for nine years at this point.
And in the process, I've amassed a library
of over 650 episodes but almost 300
of these evergreen conversations and their pearls
of invaluable wisdom are currently nowhere to be found
on YouTube simply because they predate our decision
a couple of years ago to begin filming the podcast.
Well, that ends today with the introduction
of episode 188 from way back in 2015
with the absolutely mindblowing Dr. Gabor Mate.
Fans of the show will remember
that I recently spoke extensively about Dr. Mate
with Rainn Wilson and Reza Aslan.
And a short portion of my conversation with Dr. Mate
was excerpted in our recent addiction masterclass.
That episode was so meaningful that I felt compelled
to offer it in full and for the first time here on YouTube.
Dr. Mate is a world renowned lecturer,
physician, and best-selling author
of a couple landmark books including one
of the most impactful I have ever read on the subject
of addiction called In the Realm of Hungry Ghosts.
Our conversation focused on misunderstandings,
surrounding addiction, how trauma affects addiction.
And at one point, Dr. Mate turns the interview around
to focus on me which makes it one
of my personal favorite episodes.
So, without further preamble here is episode 188
with Dr. Gabor Mate in its entirety.
(upbeat music)
Thank you so much for taking the time,
I know you're a busy guy,
I've been wanting to sit down with you for quite some time.
So, I really appreciate it.
I'm fascinated by your work.
You've been an inspiration to me in helping to understand
or better understand my own travails and struggles
and triumphs through addiction and your work is important
so thank you.
Pleasure to be here.
I thought we could start out
with kind of explaining a little bit about...
Before we get into there's so many things
I wanna talk about but just in reference to your book,
In the Realm of Hungry Ghosts,
you have such a beautiful poetic way that you open it
and explaining what that title means in the context
of the Buddhist wheel of life
so could you sort of elaborate on that?
Yeah, some Buddhist cosmologies.
We are seen as cycling through six realms
in our lives as human beings.
There's the human realm which is our ordinary selves.
You might say our everyday selves.
There's the animal realm which is our drives
or our appetites or urges or sexuality
or need to eat and so on.
There are other realms including the hell realm
which is that of suffering, rage, despair, terror,
all the uncomfortable emotions that humans can experience
to the nth degree.
There are other realms but the hungry ghost realm
is one in which the creatures are depicted as ones
with small, tiny mouse scrawniness
so very narrow gullets and huge empty bellies.
So, they can never get enough.
So they're always hungry.
And their goals, they always look they're sort
of haunting their lives looking for fulfillment
from the outside but never being able
to achieve it of course.
And that's the realm of addiction.
Yeah, it's so haunting and specific
and perfectly captures I think what my experience has been
that empty cavernous black hole
that you're constantly feeding and it can never be satiated.
You know what's interesting is I'm just rereading
for the 100th time Dante's Inferno.
And Dante begins his journey by being stuck, being lost
and buying his way from getting back onto the right path.
Is this rather than the she wolf
that the more she's hungry she gets.
So this image of the hungry creature, insatiable as being
in the way of our spiritual growth in ourselves
is obviously universal.
Right.
'Cause by Dante's coming
from a medieval Christian perspective but he did stuck
with the same thing and the very first,
the second circle of hell in Dante as people suffer
because of their chronic accumulation on earth are people
who are gluttonous.
And because they put all their attention on trying
to feed themselves rather than on-
From the external.
From the outside so that this idea
of the suffering that we create for ourselves
by seeking satisfaction, fulfillment, and satiation
from the outside, it's absolutely universal.
Yeah, and kinda taking that image
and lining it up against the people that you will see,
like if you've ever experienced being
around hardcore addicts that hollowness of the eyes
and you have amazing pictures in your book
that really capture what that is like like you can just...
You know that sort of explanation from the Buddhist wheel
is so apropos to that real life experience of what you see
if you go to skid row or do the work that you do
and the people that you interact with.
Well, I'm not on the schedule.
I mean, I don't know if you've ever looked
at our Prime Minister recently
but he's got hollowed dead eyes as well.
Yeah.
And it's interesting how it's become like this sort
of fodder for the internet and a sort of meme and a joke
but it's quite tragic because meanwhile this guy's on a,
he's on a march towards death.
Yeah.
But really my contention is that
we enter the hungry ghost realm,
I think we all do depending when and for how long
and to a degree but we all do.
It's our escape from the hell realm.
So that if we didn't go there, we'd be in hell.
So it's a desperate and unsuccessful attempt
to overcome the suffering of hell.
Right, and I think that that kinda dovetails nicely
into really a foundational aspect of your work
which is reframing the question around addiction.
And instead of asking, why the addiction,
asking, why the pain?
And this sort of more expansive perspective
on what addiction is so maybe elaborate on your perspective
of what's wrong with our kind of conventional wisdom
around the idea of addiction
and where your kinda philosophy and ideas come in.
Well, traditional wisdom around addiction
is either the legalistic one that has it as a bad choice
that people make from which they have to be deterred
by means of severe punishment tends to be
what the so-called criminal justice system
which by the way, I think is a good title,
it is a criminal system.
The justice system is criminal
the way it treats people especially-
Well, specifically addicts sort of trauma
to further traumatizing the people
that are most traumatized.
That's my point, yeah.
And who make up a large percentage so
of the jail populations on Canada, it's not surprising.
And then the same things in the states, in Canada,
30% of our jail population is first nations origin
whereas Aboriginal makeup 5% of the Canadian population.
So, we're taking the most traumatized people
and we're jailing them and we think that's justice.
There's like crazy statistics
in Saskatchewan, right?
Well, in the Prairie provinces is even higher.
Yeah, it's like 60, 70, 80% of the people
in jail are natives, they're 10%, 15% of the population.
Now, the point though is that that's the legalistic view
that addiction is a choice and people need to be punished
when they engage in addiction behavior,
addiction related behaviors.
They're very addiction being illegal.
Now the other perspective that seems different
is that addiction is a brain disease
that you largely inherit so it's not your fault
'cause you can't help what genes you inherit
but it's a disease of the brain that arises in the brain,
partly for genetic, partly for other reasons.
And what both of those perspectives share the different
as they are what they share is that in neither case
that we're looking at people's life histories.
And we're not looking at social history
or the history of a country or a nation.
So who are the populations that are most severely affected
and what happened to them and who had individuals
that are most severely affected and what happened to them.
But my perspective is that addictions are attempts
to sooth the pain in every case.
In fact, the drugs are specifically painkillers,
cocaine, numbs, and nerve endings, opiates, heroin,
these are painkillers, alcohol is a painkiller,
cannabis is a painkiller.
Crystal meth diverts you from the experience
of emotional suffering by making you feel more alive
and excited temporarily.
So it's always not why the addiction
as you said but why the pain.
Keith Richards, when he was talking about his heroin habit
in his book life which is autobiography, he said...
And I'm almost quoting him verbatim,
he said, "The contortions we go through just not
to be ourselves for a few hours."
Now, why would people not wanna be themselves?
Because they're not comfortable in their own skins,
why they're not comfortable in their own skins?
'Cause they suffered in their own skins at some point
when they couldn't help it.
So what I'm saying is that addiction in every case,
whether it's the severe addiction
of the heroin addicts that I dealt with,
or the respectable addictions of the workaholic,
or I'm probably free to mention that you talked
about your own addiction at some point,
the extreme endurance sports.
And these are always based in trauma.
So any attempt to escape the present moment has to do
with discomfort that we incurred as children.
And there are degrees of discomfort, degrees of trauma,
but fundamentally addiction is always an attempt
to escape suffering.
So it's not the problem, addiction is not the problem.
The addiction is-
No addiction is...
The manifestation of the addiction
is the solution to problem.
It's an attempt to-
And it was until
it doesn't work anymore.
It works temporarily,
that's my definition of addiction,
it's a temporary relief pleasure craving
that is satisfied momentarily
but creates negative consequences in the long-term
and you can't give it up, that's what an addiction is.
But yeah, that's what it is, it's an attempted solution,
it's not the primary problem.
And so to say that addiction is a primary brain disease
which is the official medical perspective
that I was strained in misses the whole point.
But then again, the medical profession notoriously
does not understand trauma.
Well, it's not, it's focuses and directed
in that locus sphere I suppose.
Well, but only as an artifact of denial
because the research is totally clear like it's not,
it's not that I'm giving you personal insights.
I mean I am but these insights are very much also supported
and grounded in vast body of literature
and whether we're talking about addiction or cancer.
You can look back to negative childhood experiences
and so that...
But I'm telling you, I lectured to medical students
and then all the years of medical school,
nobody ever talks to them about trauma,
they don't hear the word trauma.
Can you believe that?
Yeah, yeah.
That in 2015 students at UBC don't hear
the word trauma unless I say to them in the long lecture
that I give them in five years, in four years.
And the same thing is to enlarge universities
in the states as well so that the denial of trauma
is endemic to medical practice and in this society.
Well, I wanna get into all
the childhood development stuff in a sort of traumas
that insight this kind of behavior in so many people
but before we do that, I think it's worth kind of exploring
the more expansive idea of definition
that you adhere to in the sense that our dialogue
around addiction and addiction disease really
is focused on substance, right?
But on some level it can be argued
and I know that you argue that addiction really
is a much more mass cultural, societal issue
that can be applicable not just substances
but transcend substances to any kind of behavior pattern
that provides that dopamine release
and ultimately negative consequences in your life.
Yeah and I'm not the first one
to raise that point.
The point was raised decades ago that addiction is...
The drug addiction is one particular manifestation,
but that really you can be addicted to sex,
obviously gambling, a whole lot of respectable things
like work and the support-
Anything that takes you out of the moment
and provides a temporary relief.
What I have done in this book is about to get
into the scientific evidence of the first time.
That not only is this too psychologically,
it's also physiologically so that if you look at the brains
of sex addicts or shopping addicts or food addicts,
it's the same circus that are involved
as are involved in drug addiction.
So even on the level of physiological changes in the brain,
we're looking at the same changes just as some people use
and need chemicals to achieve those changes,
other people get it through behaviors.
But the gambler is still after dopamine hit,
dopamine being the incentive motivation chemical.
He's not after the money, 'cause it was
about the money he would quit
after he won his first jackpot.
Right?
But it's about actually the dopamine hit
that he gets, that temporary state of elation and excitement
that he gets when he's engaged in the activity.
So, all addictions whether they're behaviors
or substances or whatever they are,
they serve the same psychological purpose of escape
from suffering and pain, discomfort with the self.
And they activate the same brain circuits
with the same neurochemicals.
So there's only one universal addiction process.
Drug addiction being a small, small manifestation of that.
And because it's so divorced from logic
and rational thinking, I think that's what prevents
a lot of people from really, truly understanding it
and why the conversation around it has to do with judgment
and shame and criminology.
Well, I think if you wanna explore
that minefield, we can.
I think on the individual level the judgment and disdane
for drug addicts is actually well expressed by Jesus
when he says don't be hypocrite.
Here's the word that's the word he uses.
He says, "Before you try to remove the sliver
from your brothers eye, remove the poll from your own eye."
And so what it is is that when there's something
we don't like about ourselves,
then we'll look at that same thing as somebody else
and reject it and imagine that we're different.
So the workaholic businessman
or the workaholic doctor for that matter.
Or the shopaholic man or woman.
The guy who spends $8,000 on CDs.
CDs in a week, I've heard of people like that.
(Rich laughs)
They like to think of themselves as superior
to the drug addict.
And yet the dynamic is the same which is being in the grip
of a compulsion that you can't control.
And that has negative consequences,
and you don't have the power at least you perceive
that you don't have the power to regulate yourself.
And so we see that in somebody else.
And it's so easy then to look at the externals
which is that somebody is in a back alley
in the downtown east side of Vancouver shooting up
with heroin or cocaine or they're different
from the rest of us.
No, they're not, they're only different in their expression
of their addiction and also different
in their social economic background often.
And also of course in the degree of trauma
that they experienced as children.
Well, let's talk about backgrounds
and your perspective on the route
of addictive behavior patterns that start to form
and take place in early childhood development
and the experience or the environment
or the child rearing habitat of a young person
that begins actually in fetus according to
how you're looking at this.
Well, I have to undersize again that,
yes, it's according to how I look at it
but it's not a personal view.
I'm just talking about the research literature
and talking about the evidence.
So what we know is that already in utero,
the emotional states
of the mother affect during neurological development
of the infant.
So when a mother is a highly stressed, that infant
is experiencing a lot of stress hormones reaching him
or her through the umbilical cord.
And that interferes with healthy brain development.
And then when the child is born into satiation of stress,
many more things happen
that further affects brain development
so that the first fact to really recognize here,
which is again is not taught in the medical schools yet,
even though scientifically
it's not even vaguely controversial anymore.
Is that the brain develops an interaction
with the environment.
So when we talk about addiction as a brain disease,
yes, there's truth to that
but what shapes the brain is the environment
and the necessary condition for healthy brain development
is non-stressed parents who can really connect
with the child.
So you can see in our society
why so many people are affected 'cause
how many parents are non-stressed,
how many parents have the kind of support
that traditional societies used to provide to the clan,
the tribe, the extended family,
where the child is always around adults
who're looking after him.
Not that I wanna romanticize the past
or nor that we can go back to it, but we've lost something.
And so in this society,
it was just so disconnected alienated parents are...
Even if they're together and 40% of the time they're not,
but even if they are, they're both having to go to work,
they're both under severe strain economically very often,
relationship stresses.
The spiritual emptiness in people's lives.
Kids are being born into situations
that no longer support healthy brain development.
If on top of that, they're actually abused
which is what happens to most severe addicts,
specific abuse in some form of physical beating,
sexual exploitation, abandonment, neglect,
emotional torment that plays havoc not only
with the personality development,
not only does it give you a lot of pain
that later you have to just sued somehow,
but it also distorts your brand development.
And then, so now you have the template for addiction.
Right and so,
I mean, what happens specifically
is some sort of emotional defense mechanism is cultivated
in the brain chemistry that leads to repressing
that painful experience or how does that work actually?
Well, okay so let's separate emotional experiences
and defenses from physiological chemical events.
So, on a chemical level, take a substance like cocaine
or crystal meth or nicotine or caffeine,
these are stimulants.
They elevate the level of a chemical in the brain
which we referred to already called dopamine.
And dopamine is the incentive vitality excitement molecule.
Without that, we're listless bored, a motivated,
disinterested, you nerd.
So the dopamine circuitry is crucial to human life
and human motivation.
But the development of the dopamine circuitry depends
on the presence of a nurturing parent.
So if you dig into the monkeys
and they measure the dopamine level one week
after separation from the mother,
the dopamine levels are significantly diminished.
And dopamine receptors are diminished
when there's a lot of stress around.
Or you can isolate the monkeys or rats and put them into
an isolation cage and then measure the dopamine receptors
a month later, it's significantly diminished.
So the brain is responsive to the environment
and especially in early childhood.
So there's the chemical effects.
That's not the only one but that's one of the major ones.
But then there's the psychological defenses so that a child
under severe emotional stress has got very limited resources
to deal with that.
They can't fight back.
They can't escape and they can't change the situation.
So now the brain kicks in with its automatic defenses.
One of them is emotional shutdown.
So now you no longer have feel the emotion
'cause they're too painful.
But if you don't feel emotion,
life comes through dull and boring,
you may have to do drugs to feel better.
Right.
Or you might tune out as a way
of not experiencing the stress.
So you adapt by tuning out.
But if that gets programmed into your brain later on,
you've got this condition called ADD,
which is characterized by extreme tuning out.
So what happens is that these early defenses
help kids survive the immediate stress
but become sources of dysfunction later on.
And I have people in my life that I know
that come from a background
of pretty significant emotional stress
and any time I observed them in a scenario in which any kind
of conflict, even if it's very modest-
They'll detach.
It's almost like they go into a fugue states.
Exactly.
And you can't even reach them
and they're trying to protect themselves.
Well, they're not trying to do anything.
They're not even doing it.
It's not conscious.
No, the brain is doing it.
So the brain goes into automatic defense mode
which is programmed in childhood.
Right.
So, the point again being as you said
that early adaptations become sources of pathology
and dysfunction later on.
So we have to keep in mind that this is happening
at least on two levels.
There's the brain physiological level
which I've already talked about,
and then there's the psycho-emotional level.
And the two go along together.
And we can also talk about the relational level.
Like what happens to people
that are hurting their relationships
is that either they withdraw from relationship
at the first sign of problems
or they desperately throw themselves
into relationship hoping to be rescued.
One or the other, and now they become sex
in relationship addicts.
Right.
It happens on the spiritual level
where I think increasingly we can agree
that human beings have a need for meaning at least in life
and need for connection for belonging
in a larger sense than just the isolated ego.
Well, when you're hurt or when you're traumatized
or just when you suffer, you tend to isolate
and you lose that connection.
And so there's whether it's physiological, psychological,
emotional, physiological, spiritual, relational,
and you have to look at addiction on all these levels.
You're hobbled, you're disabled, you're impaired.
And then addiction is a desperate attempt
to avoid the impacts of all that.
Right.
And trying to better understand my own addiction
and journey through sobriety and kind of taking
the information and the wisdom that you provide,
I look back on my childhood development and my background
and certainly it's an easy case when you can...
In the example that you raised of hardcore drug addicts
that almost invariably come from some form of abuse
whether emotional or physical, in my case,
I was raised by two loving parents that are still together.
There's no great addiction of alcoholism
in my genetic background.
And so I can't...
It's been challenging for me to play the victim or to,
I'm sorry to place blame on any particular person
or my parents, it's also an uncomfortable feeling
to even examine that.
Certainly I could say, well, my parents were stressed or...
Do you want to then.
(Rich laughs)
I don't know,
sometimes my parents listen to the podcast.
Well, so what?
Yeah, so...
But look, first of all, how you phrase it,
you said first of all, play the victim.
Okay now that's a telling phrase.
In what way?
You're distancing yourself from something.
You're actually denying your own vulnerability.
It's not a question of playing victim,
It's the question of what happened to you
when you were vulnerable?
Secondly, you talk about avoiding blaming parents,
who the heck wants to blame parents, I don't blame parents.
I screwed up my kids but I don't blame myself,
I did my very best, I was a loving parent.
But I think on some level, no parents are perfect.
They're all like sort of creating emotional stress-
Yeah, but I'm telling you very specifically.
And I just had this conversation
with somebody else before I came here.
It usually takes me less than five minutes,
usually three to show somebody how they suffered
when they didn't think they did.
And that's not because I make up anything but it's
because people protect themselves for known suffering
as a way of protecting their relationship
with their parents.
And so you have a fear of alienating your parents.
Of course.
As a result of which perhaps you haven't delved
into your own experience deeply enough
to really understand it yet.
Whether you wanna do that here on air,
it's totally up to you but I'm just telling you,
that's the dynamic that I perceive all the time
and I'm also telling you,
it's not about blaming your parents.
It's not about denying that they love you,
it's not about denying that they did their very best.
We're not interested in them at all actually
in this conversation as either good guys or bad guys,
we just interested what was the experience of the child.
And then what was the impact of that experience
on the child?
This question of either being victims or blaming others,
I don't speak that language.
I'm not totally interested in either seeing people
as victims or as blaming anybody.
Well, let's play this out.
So, I mean I certainly kind of identify
with the hungry ghost idea as I said earlier,
and I was a kid who was always pretty sensitive and-
Okay, so you're sensitive.
So what does it mean to be sensitive?
It means that I'm easily impacted
by external stimuli.
That's exactly what it is.
My emotional well being.
That's exactly what it is?
So sensitive comes from a Latin word, sincere to feel.
So the sensitive child feels more so less has to happen.
If I touch you on the shoulder right now
with my fingers tapped lightly, you'd have no pain at all.
But if your shoulder was bare with a burn on it,
so your nerve endings were closer to the surface
so you were thin-skinned.
And if I tapped you with the same force,
now what would you feel?
Pain of course.
Severe pain.
And the external stimulus was the same
to anybody looking at it from the outside, what happened?
What happens is that you're very sensitive, okay.
That's the genetic factor.
Is the only genetic factor by the way.
So nobody's genetically condemned to addiction
but some people are born more sensitive than others.
Yeah, there can be a predisposition
but not a predeterminism.
And that predisposition is a sensitivity.
It's not actually a predisposition
to specific addiction either, it's just the sensitivity.
But carry on, so you were a sensitive child, so okay.
Yeah and some of the tropes that you hear
in recovery, always feeling like everyone else had roadmap
for life and kind of feeling isolated and alone
and having difficulty making friends
and connecting with people.
Okay, isolated, alone.
Every feelings is this,
ever remember feeling sad or unhappy as a kid.
Of course.
Who did you speak to about that?
Probably nobody.
Well don't get me the probably.
Yeah, well I mean it's been a while.
You know I would think that, let me think about-
Sounds like nobody.
(Rich laughs)
Yeah, I mean I was definitely a kid lost
in my own thoughts and in my own world.
Well, what saved you from it?
You don't have children yet I take it.
No, I do have kids.
Okay, you do have kids, great.
How old are they?
I have two daughters that are eight and 11
and I have two stepsons.
So you tell me if they're feeling sad and lonely,
who do you want them to talk to?
I want them to talk to me and and my wife.
Right.
And if you found out through some third source
that your children was sad and lonely
but they hadn't talked to you,
how would you understand that?
It would be heartbreaking.
No, no, but I'm not...
Yes, it would be but how would you explain it,
how would you understand it?
How would I understand what they're going through?
How do you understand
why they haven't talked to you?
I think I would understand them
as feeling unsafe and having that kind of dialogue.
And how does the child feel
when they're unsafe with their parents?
When they feel unsafe, they feel anxious.
Yeah.
They feel hurt, fearful perhaps.
Okay, that's your childhood.
Yeah.
If we say nothing more, you can see how sensitive
a child would be deeply hurt by that situation.
So by the time you have recollection,
you had already learned that your parents
on the emotional level
are somehow not quite available to you.
As much as they loved you, they didn't know how to make...
Because whatever was happening for them,
they were stressed, they were distracted,
whatever was going on.
But that doesn't matter, we're not blaming them,
we're just saying that they couldn't give you that
what you needed.
Right.
And I'm feeling like all this extreme discomfort right now
because I love my parents.
And I know that they did the very best that-
And I grant you that, and I grant you that.
But we're not, again, we're not putting them on trial.
We're just talking about what your situation was.
And what was the impact of that situation?
Now, anybody ever bullied as a kid?
Yeah, I definitely have that experience.
How old were you when you were bullied?
I think a lot of that started
when I switched schools from a school
that was relatively nurturing to my proclivities
to kind of macho kind of sports focused school
where I felt very unsafe throughout
from like 7th grade to 12th grade.
So you felt bullied there?
Yeah.
Who did you speak to about that?
I did talk to my mom.
How soon?
I would speak to her after any kind
of incident would occur at school.
And what would happen when you did?
She would comfort me
but I would return to the school.
Now, if your kid was bullied on a chronic basis
and they complained to you about it,
what would you like to do about it?
I mean, I would do anything,
I would jump in front of a train.
I would probably change our environment.
So you learned that it was futile to complain.
Again, you were left alone with it.
Guess what you became?
An endurance athlete, a matchu endurance athlete
who drove himself?
I think my first drug of choice was I discovered
the sport of swimming when I was like 12 or 14
and that was my comfort, underwater.
I even wrote my college essay about it like
that was the safe place that I could go-
Underwater.
Yeah, where nobody could get to me.
Which further isolated me of course.
I mean but I had friends and I had a community there.
I got it.
I don't know if you've read about this woman
who died a few months ago, a free diver ever,
a Russian woman, did you read that story?
I did, yeah.
You know what she said?
No, I don't.
Well, it's on my cell phone here somewhere
'cause I copied it out.
She said that underwater, you feel at one with the universe
and your mind stops and you're just totally present.
But she had to go there to achieve that state.
That state is the state that we all strive for,
under or overwater.
She could only get it underwater, she ended up dying.
No, I'm not cautioning people against free diving,
I'm just saying that she too was looking for it,
it wasn't just the physical thrill,
she was actually looking for spiritual release
and that's what you're describing as well.
Yeah there's no question that that is what
that was about, of course unconsciously at the time.
Of course unconsciously-
And I was being rewarded for it.
And so then I would double down on my commitment to that.
Yeah and I wasn't the athlete that you were.
So I got rewarded for intellectual skills.
And so that's what I built up.
And being helpful.
That's your safe place.
And that's when I say is also my addiction then,
thinking too much, helping people and all that.
So, we all use what we've got in order
to somehow divert ourselves from our pain and so...
Look, what I'm saying to you is that,
and I'm not gonna ask you more questions
about your childhood but can you possibly gap
that you've already revealed enough
to see why you might have been in emotional pain as a child?
Yes, of course.
Okay, that's all.
And how you developed the coping mechanisms to-
I would surmise that most children experience
some kind of emotional pain growing up, it's unavoidable.
So what is the distinguishing factor-
It is avoidable but not in this society.
There're societies that don't hurt their kids
like the way we do.
Yeah and there's a whole interesting conversation
that we can have about materialism and toxic culture
that I know absolutely speak to-
My next book.
But in any case, you're quite right in a society of race,
you escape that which is the way addictions
are so rife in our society.
So we're not saying there's anything uniquely horrible
about your experience on the contrary,
a lot of people had a lot worse
if you wanna compare suffering
which I don't believe in by the way.
But the point is that we're not,
it's no point in me coming to you.
Now, you tell me if at age 11 or age six,
you feel sad and lonely.
And you come and say to me, Gabor I feel sad and lonely.
Would it be any use for me to tell you,
well, don't worry about it, it's the same for everybody.
Is that what you need to hear?
No, that will further drive me
into deeper isolation and despair.
Which is what are you doing to yourself right now.
To say that everybody's like that.
So what is everybody like that?
Everybody's got their own particular experience.
And we have to honor the person's experience.
All I'm saying is that's not...
Yes, it's true that children are often hurt or isolated
and misunderstood in our society 'cause we're so unconscious
and we're so disconnected as a society.
And so harassed and hurry then stresses a culture.
That's all true.
But when it comes to understanding on,
any one particular human being that's not meaningful.
What is meaningful is
what was their own particular experience.
And if you're very sensitive as I said earlier,
less has to happen to create pain for you.
Right, so would that be the distinguishing factor
between somebody who could have had the experience
that I had and then goes on to be a social drinker
or somebody who needs sort of temporary relief
from time to time but it doesn't become...
It doesn't rise to the level of addiction
where it creates negative consequences in their life
and somebody like myself who,
you know I took it to the wall.
Sensitivity is certainly one
of the factors for sure.
But there could be other factors as well.
Maybe that other somebody's just had the one person
they could talk to who would actually understand them
and validate them, maybe.
Right so community.
Community or just even human contact with anybody.
A massive human contact,
not that you don't have human contact
but I mean, validating.
Somebody's validating your experience
and what has been called a compassionate witness.
So, as a matter of fact I mean as you all know
from recovery, what makes the difference ultimately
is not just one's own individual willpower
and determination, but also others who can listen
to you compassionately and validate your experience
and not judge you.
Yeah I mean my journey has been one of trying
to overcome my predisposition towards self-will
and self-reliance to a place of surrender.
Because when I track back over the course of my life,
it's very easy for me to make an argument that everything
that happened that was good growing up or any accomplishment
that I was able to do is a result of my work ethic
and doubling down and being focused
to overcome whatever circumstance I was in
to kind of get to the next level.
Addiction, my alcoholism was the first instance
in which that no longer was applicable and the more
that I try to apply myself well to this problem,
the deeper the hole that I dug for myself.
Right.
Until I could surrender
as you will hear all the time is so closely aligned
with this idea of giving up which is so antithetical
to the way that I wanted to approach my life
so it was a journey to get to that place of willingness
in order to entertain a different way.
And my point is that some people criticize
the first step as you know admitting
that you're powerless is...
Why you're telling people that they're abused,
that they're powerless.
My point is the opposite, that it's when you admit
that you're powerless that you gain power.
That you actually-
Of course.
When you actually get how it is.
Why is it so difficult to understand that?
Well, because the people will make that argument
are still identified with their childhood vulnerabilities.
And so I'm never gonna make myself powerless again.
They think that powerlessness
in that sense opens you up to being hurt.
We're actually...
That surrender is actually the way of, out of the hurt.
But let me come back to you just for a moment.
So this ethic that you had that I need to do this myself
and I can do this and so on.
Well, think about that.
Do you want your kids to have that?
No.
How would you make sure that they don't?
I would imagine by trying to help them
to understand that making your way in the world
is an interdependent act.
That the way the path towards whatever your goal is
or your dreams, your aspirations for your life
is contingent upon the community that you cultivate.
Okay, so that's intellectually too,
but how will you support that understanding in them?
I think by trying to help them foster an ethic
of open communication and feeling safe with communicating.
With whom?
Well, with myself and my wife first and foremost,
and then their siblings
and then extrapolating out from there.
That's the whole point.
So that's what you lacked.
And then we developed a coping mechanism,
I can do this all by myself.
No.
It is true that you want to foster self-reliance
and internal resilience and initiative, that's true.
But the pathway towards doing that is the same
as the pathway towards fostering relational health
which is by giving the children the environment
where they can actually feel listened to
and validated and supported.
And this is what so many of us didn't get.
It might be interesting for you at some point
to speak with your parents and if depending
on the relationship that you have with them say,
okay look, just tell me about your marriage
when I was a kid.
Not mine what you didn't do for me,
like I know you did your very best,
I love you very much, I honor you.
But tell me about your lives.
What was it like for you?
What stresses were you under?
What were you carrying from your own childhood?
Yeah, I mean I can-
What was happening in your larger family,
were there work stresses?
Just what, how was your relationship?
All those questions.
Yeah I mean, I think in my mother's case
she suffered a tremendous amount of trauma in her life.
She lost her father when she was still in college
and then when I was very young,
she lost her brother in a car accident.
Oh my God, now you mentioning-
It's tremendous amount of pain in her life
and stress and it's manifested in stress and anxiety
and being somebody who is very risk averse.
And I think that that manifested in my life as a parent
who was perhaps over-protective.
However, there's no such thing as over protective,
you can either protective or not protective.
What you're talking about is controlling.
Now that comes out of anxiety.
She was anxious so she wanted to protect you by controlling.
But the impact on you is loss of autonomy.
And just imagine your poor mother state of mind
when her brother dies.
She just lost her father not that many years before,
now she's a relatively young mom and she loses her brother
in a car accident.
And then she's got the small child to look after.
What could be your state of mind?
I mean it's informed her world view
and I think that made her kind of terrified
of externalities that she can't control.
But it also just a state of mind.
Would it be sadness, grief,
maybe depression, a lot of stress.
And sadness, grief, depression, stress acts
as a screen between the parent's love
for the child and the child.
And it's nothing that the parent is doing on purpose.
So we know for example that postpartum depression
is a significant risk factor
for childhood developmental problems.
It's got nothing to do with
how much the mother loves the child, how devoted she is.
It just children pick up
on their parents' emotions automatically and they imbibe,
they absorb the parents' emotions
and they think it's about them.
So when my mother's side as my mother was
because of the situation as I write about in the book
in the second world war,
a Jewish family in Nazi occupied Hungary.
Her grief and her own happiness to the infant means
that she's not happy with me.
So my self esteem is undermined.
Not 'cause my mother didn't love me,
she love me fiercely and desperately.
But just because children absorb
and are shaped by the emotional states of their parents.
And those emotional states are not deliberate
on the part of the parent.
And your mother was not a grief struck grieving young mother
because she wanted to be.
But the fact that she was.
And furthermore, if you were living in a clan based society
where there's a lot of aunts, uncles, elders, neighbors,
even living under the same roof perhaps.
Well then that mother who has suffered
that loss has got a lot of support.
And the impact of that one singular person
on a young child's life is diminished and replaced
in some part by other people that can pick up the slack
and provide a tapestry of emotional support.
This is how you're right
and that's why it takes a village.
Yeah it does.
We try to cultivate that with our kids too,
we have a very much of a open house kind of situation
with lots of people coming in and there's a lot of adults
that are around our kids for that very reason.
Wonderful, yeah which is wonderful.
And we've moved away from that,
it is true and it's...
It's a society gap.
In this internet culture
of seemingly never being more connected than we are,
we're lonelier and more isolated than ever.
Yeah, so then we talk about why are...
Yeah, so to go back to your original point.
Yes, there are very few children in our society
who are not significantly affected
by these dynamics regardless of the parents' best efforts.
Now, until we get conscious around it and it sounds like you
and your parenting had developed some consciousness.
But most of us just sort of try and get by.
You're just trying to pay the bills
and put food on the plate.
And to keep the relationship going
and do the right thing and we're not conscious
of what we've lost as a society.
And your own consciousness was probably gained at
or through dealing with your own addictions.
You're probably much more conscious as a parent.
Oh of course.
And it's that adage of being the grateful alcoholic
because it's catapulted me into a life based more
on spiritual principles than maybe
or perhaps I would have ever been introduced to
but when I went away to college, I went the other coast
and that's when I discovered drugs and alcohol.
And that was the solution that I wasn't the problem,
that was what made me feel whole until it played itself out
and took me to some dark places.
But as that kind of unfolded,
predictably that's where the shame and the low self-esteem
and the self-judgment and all of that comes in as you start
to bifurcate into this kind of double life existence
that further isolates you and alienates you
from your community.
I'm almost impelled to say that you were fortunate
to have become an alcoholic because you see my addictions
to work and to shopping, they're respectable ones.
You don't suffer the consequences to the same degree
so that you don't get the same wake up call.
No, I'm not wishing I wasn't, I'd been an alcoholic
but actually if I'm honest about it,
sometimes when I meet people who've been through recovery
from severe addiction, there's a sense of envy almost
because they've really been forced
by their intense suffering to go very deep with themselves
Well pain is the only thing
that really motivates people to change their ways right.
So how much pain can you bear before?
I know but unfortunately it was only pain,
there'd be a lot less suffering.
It takes more than just pain but yeah, it's true.
There's a line I'm reading in a Greek play I was looking
through recently where they say we suffer into truth.
We suffer into truth and so the more intense
the suffering sometimes the deeper
the appreciation of truth.
And a lot of the spiritual teachers will tell you that.
I'm reading Eckhart Tolle these days
and with a lot of gratitude.
And he talks about how sometimes the suffering is so intense
that it just burns away the ego.
And then you get the truth.
Yeah but I would say also,
I'm interested in your perspective on this.
So, I get sober and my sobriety is buttressed by community
and the 12 steps and the principles and the sort of work
that I do in that program service oriented
and sort of living my life premised
on these spiritual principles that have really given me
this amazing life that I'm very grateful for
and yet at the same time, I'm certainly not cured.
It's like having all of these things in place
to keep me walking the correct path.
It's still a process.
What would cure mean to you?
Cured would mean that that's the impulse to drink
or use or to try to check out of the present
through any number of behavior patterns
that are inconsistent with how I would like to live my life
that create negative consequences
no longer enter my consciousness.
So you would like a Jesus or whatever-
(Rich laughs)
Yeah.
If there's a high ambition.
I would.
Yeah, okay.
Well, good luck with that.
But I mean kind of in brass tacks day to day life,
you know gratitude is a fleeting experience for me.
My default state is not gratitude,
my default state is irritability, anxiety,
judgement, frustration.
Yeah, my default state is irritability as well.
Well now look, what you're talking about now is...
First of all let's just eliminate the word cure here.
And nothing will cure, we're talking about wholeness.
And it just means you've got more work to do.
So it's a question of how committed you are to the work.
And I know for me, those are my default states as well,
I can't help that, I can't help it that's my default state,
I didn't create that, that's a consequence of experiences.
What I can make a choice about is how I relate
to all that and how I live my life
and what structures supports, practices do I engage in
that helps me deal with that irritability when it arises.
That urge to check out when it arises.
So that's very much up to me.
This is my 4th book and it's had tremendous response
and as have my others and I travel a lot speaking all
over North America and internationally.
And very often people have said to me, boy,
I wish I had read your book 30 years ago
and my joke always was, gee, maybe I should read it myself
because on the one hand I can say these things
and teach people and help people
but there was this tremendous gap
between my internal and personal life.
And what I can manifest on the stage or in a seminar room.
And I can say no, but I'm 71.
And I can say now that that gap is narrowing significantly.
But that's because I'm actually doing the work.
Yeah, the aspiration is the commitment to the work
and to the process, right?
So if you're doing the work,
then inevitably it'll pay off and it's not helpful
to talk to yourself about...
To talk about yourself as not being cured,
you're not a piece of meat, you don't have to be cured.
You're just need to integrate.
And that's a lifelong process and again,
as Eckhart Tolle says that for some people it happens
as a sudden illumination.
That's essentially what happened to him.
But for more people, it's work, it's ongoing work.
Yeah I mean self knowledge is insufficient,
I could read your book cover to cover,
I could read it every week for the rest of my life
but if I don't extract from your book principles
that can translate into actions that I can take
on a daily basis to narrow that gap,
then it's not really going to help me or anyone else.
It's the practice.
Yeah.
And I was pointed in another dimension there.
Is that there's a difference of in self knowledge
and knowledge about the self.
Explain that.
Well, you can know about yourself intellectually
but that wouldn't be self knowledge,
self knowledge is experiential.
We actually experienced you to self, that self knowledge.
It's got nothing to do with the intellect.
And you're totally right,
I could read all these wonderful books
that I have over the years, make dozens.
I could write these books full of insight
and I'd say wisdom and finance.
That's not self knowledge.
That's knowledge about the self.
And it's a different level of knowing because we have...
There's different levels of knowing,
there's the intellectual knowing,
there's the intuitive knowing
and there's experiential knowing.
And the deepest one is the experiential one
that you've actually, yes, this is the self, here I am.
And even then that takes practice to maintain
that space because the world's so quickly robs you of it.
I think alcoholism and addiction are ciphers
to compel one to face that and walk that path
and undertake that journey.
Yes.
But for, I'm putting myself in the shoes
of somebody who might be listening
who is not afflicted in that way or at least on a,
I mean in your mind, it's a spectrum and-
They fit in in a different way.
Different way perhaps less severe
the idea of experiential self knowledge
or what that journey would look like is a foreign concept
to a lot of people like how does one even begin
to crack the seal on what that means on a day-to-day basis?
Well, look, I mean, the Buddha,
when he sat under the Bodhi tree
and meditated all those days after having followed this
or that practice of severe abstention
or self flagellation and spiritual exploration.
He was dealing with the problem of human suffering,
which is not restricted to specific addicts only,
it's the human condition because that disconnection
from the self happens to everybody.
And everybody suffers.
Now, we can cover up that suffering
with the munificence of our consumer society,
and that's why the desperation by the way.
The great Henry David Thoreau quote,
"the massive men lead lives of quiet desperation
and what is considered resignation
is confirmed desperation."
Yeah.
So I'm not sure that you're right about the listener
who hasn't suffered addiction and afflicted
in the same degree, people in all walks
of lives know somehow...
And they believe and say, I just don't know myself,
I don't know who I am, I don't know what's my purpose
in life and all that so those are all states
of disconnection from the self,
very common in our society.
So I actually think a lot of people would understand
what we're talking about
even if they haven't suffered degrees of trauma
and compensations for trauma such as maybe you have
or to the degree that I have.
So in a real-world context,
the process of beginning to probe into the deeper,
more authentic self within, what is the practice of that?
By recognizing...
Well, again, since I'm reading that Eckhart these days
I'll quote him, he says that mankind's greatest achievement
is not our architecture and our science and our creations
but the recognition of our own insanity.
So, the first thing is you gotta get
that it's not working for you.
Yeah.
I mean if you don't get that,
you just continue to tread the same.
Well, there's so many layers
that have to be peeled back.
I mean, we're immersed in...
And this gets into toxic culture and materialism
like the society in which we live in is predicated
upon these ideals that are in certain respects antithetical
to this journey, we're sort of fed this message
of climbing the corporate ladder
and Keeping Up with the Joneses
in a competitive kind of accumulation focused
and prioritized way of living
that is simply fomenting more suffering
and further divorcing ourselves from that true nature.
So you have to be able to pierce that
to even begin I would think.
You just have to get that you're suffering.
I mean, you just have to get that, that's the first thing.
If you don't know that you're suffering,
you're not gonna pierce anything.
You're not gonna look for anything.
So, then you can study.
And if you realize that you're suffering,
then you can start asking the question why.
And then you can look at your own life
and you look at society and everything else
but it's gotta begin with some sense
that things ain't right with you.
Now, here's...
I can give you any number of courts.
The Tibetan Book of Living and Dying talks about
how the selling of samsara which is of illusion
is the major function of our society.
And here's Thomas Merton who is a Catholic monk
and spiritual teacher who wrote in 1948 or 50s,
I don't remember this.
It says it is true that the materialistic society,
the so-called culture that has evolved
under the tender mercies of capitalism has produced
what seems to be the ultimate limit of worldliness
and nowhere perhaps except in the analogous society
of pagan room has there ever been such a flooring of cheap
and petty and disgusting lust and vanities
in the world of capitalism where there's no evil
that is not fostered and encouraged
for the sake of making money.
And he talks about that we restrain every human limit,
every desire, every human desire to the limit to create
as many new desires and synthetic passions as possible
in order to cater to them with the products of our factories
and printing presses and movie studios and all the rest.
This is 60 years before the internet
or 50 years before the internet.
So that we live in a society
that feeds off the hungry ghost.
And so we keep creating...
And nobody's does this deliberately,
although actually they do.
They did yeah,
I was gonna take issue with that here.
But you know what?
But they can't create the hungry ghost.
They can cater to it but they can't create it.
Another it's a Coca Cola company might tell you
that the greatest joy in the world is to drink a can
of coke is what they're telling you
that nothing means as much as drinking a can of coke,
but you have to be hungry ghost to believe it.
And then comes in this the persistence
of this illusion that it will lead to your happiness
is astonishing.
Despite never reaching it,
you think that this is the next time
where it's actually going to work.
Well a doctor friend of mine said
that it's hard to get enough...
It's difficult to get enough of something that almost works.
(Rich laughs)
That's the thing, right?
If you can come up with that very product,
then you will be a master of capitalism.
Yeah, and I can thank you too,
if only I achieved this, I attain that.
If my books sell this many copies or if I'm on this program
or if I buy this many compact disks,
then I'll be complete and happy.
it's always that next thing.
Of course.
And by the way and there's
a Buddhist teacher said, just one more is the binding factor
in the cycle of suffering.
Right.
And it leaves me wondering if Eckhart Tolle checks
his Amazon ranking or has he transcended
the mortal coil in that regard.
It would be interesting to find that-
I mean we all live in the world as does he.
It'd be interesting to find out,
my guess is that he would not be checking that.
Yeah, I would imagine he does that.
But yeah, just the way I read him
and not just in his reading but when I see him
in his videos and one time in person,
he doesn't strike me that he used to do that.
And even for myself, I don't need to do it either.
Not that I don't ever but it fluctuates.
So the degree to which I'm impelled to do a depends on-
Well it's a barometer of your spiritual
and emotional health.
At that moment, exactly yeah.
So now I don't think so, I don't think that he would,
I'd be very much surprised if he did.
Well we're running out of time and there's
a couple of things I still wanna talk to you about.
I mean really kind of the core undercurrence
of your message with respect to how we kind of treat
and perceive addicts and addiction culture
is really a cry for more empathy and love.
And the idea that a man's natural state
is one of empathy and love.
And so when we were talking about how you and I share
this predisposition to irritability or anxiety
or what have you-
Programming.
Yeah, it's this program.
I think I heard you in another interview saying
the idea of second nature came up.
It's my second nature to be anxious, to be irritable.
And just let's dissect that phrase second nature
because it implies that we have a first nature.
Exactly and then our first nature is according
to all the scientific research
or at least overwhelming scientific research
is that our two natures to be compassionate, to be sharing,
to be cooperative, to be loving actually.
None of which is championed in our culture.
But the opposite is championed.
So that is our first nature and we suffer precisely
because we divorced from our first nature.
Yeah it's that separation from that true state
that is the kernel of suffering that gets fertilized.
Yes.
And so it also means that since it is our first nature,
then our true nature, even the word recovery,
what does it mean?
It mean it was to find something right.
To return to a natural state.
Yeah, exactly.
So the recovery actually is returning to
who we actually are.
But the who and the what that we are
that we got disconnected from.
And that's what it means to recover.
And that can be a lifelong process but it's not a bad thing.
That's not a bad thing.
It's a worthy journey to undertake.
'Cause it's not about,
as with all journeys it's not about...
If you do it right, it's not about the destination.
It's about the destination when you get there,
but it's not about a destination,
it's about each step along the way.
And the willingness to undertake that step.
Yeah.
And to keep generating that willingness
'cause I can say I have the willingness Tuesday,
but it totally absent for me on Wednesday.
And then I have to look at what's going on here?
So, it's just a constant willingness to engage
with however it is at that moment.
And whenever I've thought of arrived somewhere,
life will come along and say,
buddy, you think you have arrived somewhere,
let me just show you exactly where you're at.
And then something will happen that will show me exactly.
Yeah, that mirror will show up.
The mirror will always shows up
and it shows up pretty quickly.
Yes.
Well, I wanna close it down with one final question,
which is if you woke up in some bizarre parallel universe
and found yourself to be a surgeon general,
in the United States.
Understanding that the system is what it is
and is inherently limited in that regard,
where would your focus be placed in terms of changing policy
and reframing legislation around recovery and-
I would pass a law.
(Rich laughs)
I would pass a law that says it's illegal
to use the word addict.
That every time you wanted to use the word addict,
instead you have to say he or she,
you can't use as an addict.
You'd have to say he or she is a human being
who suffered immensely and is turned to substances
or their behaviors to suit their suffering.
So that every time you thought of addiction or an addict,
you have to frame it in those terms.
That would immediately transform the conversation
and it would immediately be self-evident of how destructive,
inhumane, retrograde our current attitudes are
and our current policies are.
And when I say attitudes and policies,
I mean the legal ones,
the psychological ones and the medical ones.
So, it would be just to reform the conversation,
reframe the conversation.
You can say I don't really believe in...
You can't legislate compassion.
You can legislate cruelty
but you can't legislate compassion.
So, in fact I'm part
of a new nonprofit called Compassion for Addiction.
And I think that actually,
if we adopted that attitude of compassion
and if we talked about it in the terms that I just outlined,
we would have not only a much more fruitful approach
to treating addiction,
we'd also be a lot happier as a society
because it will be much more closer to who we really are
which is compassionate and social minded.
I love that, that's beautiful.
Yeah.
Thanks for talking to me today.
It's my pleasure, thank you.
So many things that I had jotted down
in my notebook here I wanted to talk to you about
that we didn't even come close to getting to
so perhaps I can convince you to sit down with me
at some future point and continue the conversation.
Yeah, why don't we do that
when my next book comes up.
That would be great, happy to do that.
I appreciate all the work that you're doing,
it's making a large impact and it is changing lives
and it's inspiring to hear your message and just thank you.
Well, thanks so much.
All right, peace.
Cuts.
(upbeat music)